so I just got an email in and it looks
like we we have to channel back so I am
gonna surprise Greg with this
information I think he's still asleep or
something I don't know if he knows yet
but Greg buddy hey okay yeah we just got
an email back and it looks like we're
probably never
Greg Greg what are you going man come on
Greg Greg Greg we got the job
oh my goodness we are back what I think
this is on YouTube
we've just been sitting here for weeks
weeks is refreshing the page that's all
we've done wondering where all the
comments videos oh guys we've been gone
for three weeks off of youtube if you
guys don't follow us on social media I'm
sure you have no idea what's happened
with our channel why we haven't been
around but we'll give you it we're gonna
give you a full explanation today talk
about the experience a little bit and
have some thank yous to give as well
yeah just so you guys know I'm gonna put
this at the very beginning of the video
there are about 30 videos Facebook and a
lots of patreon - as for early access
from when we did get our hands back on
the channel I don't want to do a 30
uploads in one day because the way
algorithm works and the way however
whenever you upload we lose subscribers
right away funny enough we've gained
about 3,000 followers that happen but
yeah that's just a heads up about the
uploads we might as well just go into it
of what happened to the channel I've had
to explain it to so many different
people over the course of three weeks
that I feel like I've I've gotten really
good at efficiently explaining it so
here's how it goes it's all started the
day after we put up the infinity war
reaction and that was such a great day
that day taught John and I a hell of a
lot about especially how I wanted to
keep doing the channel how we want to
run the channel specifically it was
awesome because we pulled an all-nighter
we shot a sketch edited it put it it's
only like a minute and a half but we
loved it and we put it before the
reaction we gotta react one of the first
ones good or reaction up video hit the
trending page I saw one point it was
number 11 on the trending page which was
really cool and then John and I felt
like I actually got to at least nine
really yeah oh it did yes we saw a bunch
of different ones throughout I think
it's our only video that ever it's not
our most viewed video but it's our only
video that I think has ever actually hit
the trending page so that was really
sweet and then then we want to take a
nap because he earned it and then it
started problem started happening the
video got claimed by someone who was was
not like it wasn't Marvel or and it
wasn't Disney so when when the studio
claims it for the reaction we're like
alright whatever not much you can really
do about it
but it was some random claim that had no
time stamp on it and whenever you get a
man whenever you get a claim from a
studio they give you a time span for
when they're like well we're not cool
with you using this but we'll keep the
video up this was some claim that we
didn't understand and then we were
trying to fight it because our video was
trickling with so many view counts and
from like a random music distribution
company and they hit everybody they hit
a lot of people it hit every single
person but they hit a lot of people
everyone might have made money yeah and
then after a few days they eventually
did lift the claim but at the time that
it wasn't lifted so it was a very
stressful day and then the next day it
was our day to receive our payment and
if you guys don't know how payments work
with YouTube especially if you're a
partner with a multi-channel network and
what a multi-channel network is most a
lot of youtubers especially after you
have like maybe around 30 to 50 K you
get partnered with a multi-channel
network and they're essentially like a
manager for your channel they help you
with your ads they their support
distribution they have always a pumping
year they can help with product
placement deals and and so how it works
is even if you don't have an MCN you
always get paid a month after the the
month is over so for example if you do
videos for june from june to june 30th
you won't get that money to August 1st
probably somewhere around that timeframe
yeah and then when we got our money it
was less and keep in mind the money that
we're earning over YouTube that's going
for two of us you know and to pay them
to pay the bills to pay the rent of
everything and to take care of our
personal bills
and the money accumulate that we
received was less than 10% of our
earnings which wasn't even enough to
take care of like utilities a scary
situation yes so that came in in 10% and
then that caused us to have to go in and
look at a different issue which had
started you know nine or so days earlier
with our MCN basically on the YouTube
Adsense pays out on the 21st and that's
the day that we had some kind of
disconnection error from our MCM so in
trying to sort all that stuff that is
mound of it we already have like well
we're trying to get this claim lifted
and now we're now we're not paid and
rent to fight this guy gotta do all this
stuff and then and then through the
process of trying to sort it out somehow
our email got disconnected from the
YouTube channel meaning there was no way
of us logging into the channel yeah
which is weird because we've never had
another email we've never assigned to a
different account it's always just been
us so we've spent the past few weeks
just really trying to get our channel
back by the simple process of
reconnecting our email but the thing
with communicating with YouTube is it
always takes a long time to hear
responses we called Google a bunch of
times we managed to find a number to
call Google we've talked with so many
different people who were talking to
YouTube talking with our network and at
this point right now now that we have
the channel back and we woke up to news
that we got it back after a lot of work
so thank you to fullscreen our
multi-channel network for finally
helping us get this solved we still
haven't gotten who the earth we still
haven't gotten a so we have to sort that
out and there's sub all these problems
get solved in reverse order so no one is
getting much in oh yeah and the in terms
of the uploads the reason we're not
gonna upload today is because there's
still some technical things that kind of
boring mumbo-jumbo that we have to sort
out first before getting back up
everything's up and up before we start
going to business as usual
yeah and what helps save us was to be
able to make the the bills so we can you
know still have a place to live and
still do videos in the meantime to be
ready for the child comes back is the
sponsorship with Stardust and this month
and everyone at patreon and everyone
patreon has been super supportive and
super kind yeah it's it's been an
incredible journey and I want to tell
you guys a little bit about our
emotional experience our lesson patreon
both really saved they saved our asses
Inc they saved our asses you know we
were able to still have a place to sleep
which is yeah that's priority way yeah
so what I wanna cover a little bit about
is the emotional experience because to
me this was one of the worst and somehow
one of the ironically best experiences
I've ever had in terms of YouTube
character building man it's an
absolutely life challenge absolutely you
can't go to work I mean beyond it being
work necessarily cuz the first few days
I was just in a really negative mood
like I think John and I both were just
in a very stressed negative mood I was
like about a temper just ready to
explode at some point it was bad at him
we were having tension because it was
just there's just a lot of chaos and and
then and then one day I decided that I
had a talk with a couple of friends
thanks Marcelo chelina and my girlfriend
Olivia you guys really helped out a lot
my girlfriend was so patient and she's
been she really helped us out a lot yeah
I found numbers for us to call and
support like she was huge with YouTube
at all she see there is stuff are like
no we can't do that that you would
figure it out for one and just helping
keep morale up - yeah she's been huge
for that so what ended up happening in
this emotional journey was I started
taking I started had to ask myself like
what is the point of this experience how
can we have a video go trending for the
first time ever and now we don't get
paid we don't have any access to the
channel now to ride the momentum and
wave hey you know it's like a weird
forced mic drop it's like biggest video
here training page we're done yeah so I
started asking myself like what are we
supposed to learn from in a lot a lot
came to be learned from it what and
there's several things I want to talk
about one was mainly the big thing is
about with John and I the relationship
with John a little bit BTS your
behind-the-scenes stuff is you know like
when John and I started doing some
sponsorship stuff and patreon that was
there's no real need to explain it's
because of the algorithm change in the
ad pocalypse that happened that we had
to supplement that income because the
the the earnings off of YouTube alone
dropped by like somewhere between 70 to
80 percent it's just not the same living
it used to be and you gotta adapt and in
terms of sponsorships every sponsorship
deal we do we always review what it is
first there's plenty of sponsorship
deals we've been offered that we don't
agree to there's plenty that we don't
agree to yeah and but the ones we do
agree to it's more than just like
getting the extra earning it's also we
want to make sure this does line up in
some capacity what we're doing we try to
we try to temper the balance yes we need
you know I'd be lying if we said the
rate means nothing but we we don't only
look at that we try to bring as much
stuff in that matches yeah vibe or or
that's practical and somehow like one
time we got offered a thousand dollars
to review a movie that we both didn't
like yeah we didn't like it enough to
give them the kind of reason so we're
like thousand bucks sounds great right
now
but we're not gonna do it because we
don't like the movie you know
and so Stardust has been an incredible
sponsorship in that process we even got
a chance to more star those videos yeah
because of the fact that we did and our
following they're still growing yeah you
know like it would and our way our rep
Jake has been so understanding as we've
been going through this process because
you know like you're contractually
obligated to do some stuff and we love
working with Stardust specifically we're
not just saying that
yeah this this situation has cost us
some some deals and and Jake and and
Stardust's have been so so terrific to
stick and yeah and and
even you know still working I mean you
know still working with us on stuff you
know yeah it's not even been checked
back in when the channels back it's like
now let's keep moving but in terms of
like the earnings and the work put in of
who's putting in work here and what not
and then when John lost his job then we
decided to like okay this has become
full-on partners with the rejects right
now let's move in figuring out the money
situation has been rough and then I
realized in this process that ever since
had pocalypse this is what slowing down
and have a channel got me to realize
that ever since that apocalypse like I
love doing the videos we love filming
and I mean we've been getting back to
that that point in the past few months
again where we just really love filming
and I realize I don't want to think
about the money now you know because
when you lose that large percentage of
money you start just thinking about you
don't motivation the money yeah because
that's why I think the infinity war
video did so well it's like yeah it's
infinity worse that's gonna do well
because it's the biggest trailer of the
year but regardless of that when we saw
the comments that day it was mainly
about our sketch and we we heard it was
getting shared a lot because of the
sketch and that's because even during
the reaction part we had a lot of love
and enthusiasm for that specific portion
of it and we even loved doing the
reaction part it's just so much
excitement that was we weren't we
weren't thinking about views we weren't
thinking about money we were just we
just wanted to make the most fun video
possible yeah this event that whole
morning felt like some kind of event
yeah it felt like a like a for 24 hours
it was the most fun we've had having
together easily that was the most fun
because we got to be creative and also
do what we love to do in the commentary
section in the reaction side another
thing that it got me to realize too was
you guys might not I've been around for
this if you're watching this video but a
couple year or two ago something like
that there's a whole situation with
another YouTube channel that I don't
think he's around anymore a great a
under a where this is when reaction
channels were getting a lot of crap and
you know III felt like I had to defend
myself being like well we're more than a
lot of reaction channels we do a lot of
commentary we give a lot of reviews
before there was like I'd variety before
there was other movie channels doing the
reaction to review stuff I know we were
the first ones to feel confident have to
be like yeah we actually really review
these videos even the YouTube video
reactions I feel like 95% of them we
provide commentary makeup on to put more
than just the reaction we make a point
to make it like if the commentary part
would be enough to be a video in and of
itself without the reaction yeah it's
like if your only concern for the
reaction great but if you want there to
be something to justify beyond that then
we also got that too but the part that
started getting to me
that kind of seeped into my subconscious
that I realized was still there from the
gray day under a experience with all the
hate was that I started getting to a
point where I started forgetting like
why do people like reactions that's kind
of just been in my mind you know that
without realizing that that's been in my
mind is that oh it's not worthy of being
good enough for stuff and I realize like
people love reactions because of the
fact that they get a live vicariously
and get experience with a friend
yeah what's what their experience and
it's also just one form of hanging out
you know even if it's a quiet reaction
if I'm watching a youtuber I like who's
doing a reaction to something if they're
not really reacting it's just
fascinating to see their their facial
expressions and their instant commentary
on what they're saying and in terms of
the commentary part I think that we can
provide good insight and I think that we
can be very entertaining and I think we
can make people laugh so I'm like yeah
we have a show and it's worth it's
worthwhile so I started realizing our
our value a lot more in this process too
and then in terms of Jon and I we were
just like you know it was just stick to
doing what we love doing like what do we
where do we want this channel to go we
took time to think about that like where
do we want this channel to go where do
we want it to be what's the big goal
with it and you know like with terms of
money like now let's just help each
other take care of each other's bills
and just keep doing what we love doing
because at the end of the day that's
what just does best on YouTube is if
we're not concerned about people
pleasing if we're not concerned about
money and we're just all we care about
is we want to make sure whatever videos
were putting up we
love doing we just want it we want to do
these videos so just keep doing that so
that's been a really big help and it
also got us a chance to think of a
couple of new ideas of things that we
want to do like there's a there's a new
segment that we're thinking of doing
that I ran by a few patrons and they
seem really enthusiastic about it so we
want to implement a new segment more
discussion videos as well well so keep
the reactions going because we love
doing that and also I have a little
guideline here oh yeah upload zoo
tomorrow and and also I I did want to
take time out to give some major thank
yous to some people in this process
because while it's been a lifelong we've
learned to relaxes it takes that you you
learn something when you're put in a
position of survival and you just have
no choice but to slow down and not
stress because it's like if we're
worrying that does no good we have to
just be grateful and be patient and be
positive and stop putting out negative
vibes to the Internet to about like
channels down did it I realize there's
one day where I want John like you know
III think that I'm not gonna keep
bitching about it to people I'm not
gonna keep complaining about it to
anyone I just want to just find a way to
proceed yeah I just want to be
optimistic about and genuinely optimist
I felt like something I don't know for
sure if you did but my aunt I did get to
a point where I'm like yeah I'm not
worried about anymore I feel like we'll
get it back one day and when we get it
back we'll just go gung-ho with it yeah
yeah once you calm down and once you
also accept the indefinite nature of the
coz you know I mean throughout this
process the only consistency has been
like there's not really much Pacific
like specificity yeah and we don't know
when anything's gonna happen so after a
week or so you start to be like well I
know it can be sorted out and I know
it'll take some time so let's just use
the time in the yeah yeah I was we
haven't been kicking it we've been doing
a lot of patreon a lot a lot of Facebook
stuff a lot of building social media
there's been a lot and like a lot of
prepping for one week
it's been good for for things like that
it's helped to grow our social media and
to open us up to yeah avenues and and
you know broader places to put things
yeah yeah and and then a week ago I I
put out a tweet asking for people to
please retweet this as we're doing
whatever we can to get energy directed
towards getting the channel back in a
positive manner yeah so I put out a
tweet asking for people to please
retweet it with an explanation of the
situation a lot of great friends of ours
really put retweeted it for us or some
people had texted specifically to help
us out so want to give thank you so
those guys Brianne Chandler and Stacie
Howard from hit or miss movies or missed
movies Tyrone Magnus you know everyone
knows Tyrone Brianna wide from strange
rebel gaming dance cyber from that cyber
channel Alyssa be crazy KC Spivey from
Screen Rant Kristian harloff yeah I was
really happy he retreated Ashley Edna
and Morgan Han from how Tuesday Morgan
and Ashley John Roca and Perry Nemiroff
and Wendy leave from Collider videos
Aimee castle and author who I had a
great dinner with named Caleb Cala
wanted to interview me for this book
he's writing he was really supportive
Lisa mihalick the flick pick John
Flickinger he retweeted us screen
junkies and Joe star and John Bailey
thank you guys
acha saw my man Lauren Francesca who has
been checking up on us like every other
day and retweeted on everyone Thank You
Kyle
alderman from fan theory Tara Erickson
egg or 7-eleven Andrew quarter from the
movie source channel of course our great
friend Anita Starr and big big big
special thank yous mainly to my brother
javi kawaii on the internet because we
we knew that most of our following is on
YouTube and not on our social media so
we wanted to try to get the word out and
he let us upload a couple of videos on
his channel directly he he helped get us
in touch her creators support because
when you're locked out of YouTube you
can't so he really helped us out with
that so thank you my brother
and son all Iike our contact at YouTube
has been very good at communicating with
us lately so thank you my girlfriend
Olivia like we said has been a great
great moral support and has put up with
my negativity
that first week so much so patient with
me always understanding no matter how
like hopeless I forget she would just be
right there to just be a positive
support rock for me to bounce off of and
last but not least our reps a rep Brian
and then a person at fullscreen who
worked with us Taylor Brian and Taylor
as a full screen you guys helped us get
the channel back so major major thank
you to you guys it's true yes yes
there's a benefit to having a
multi-channel network right well
oftentimes I meet the youtubers
sometimes I've asked myself that too
like what's the benefit of having a
multi-channel network and this was a
prime example of that so thank you oh
yes especially if you need to deal with
the machine itself cuz you know I mean
partly through this what I've had to
remind myself throughout this whole
experience is that is annoying as is and
as much as yeah there should be like a
good system for this YouTube is such a
gigantic intricate vast machine and it
is hard to reach people there and so
Brian and Taylor you they manage to
react them you know much better and more
effectively than we could on our own so
absolutely absolutely so with all that
in mind thank you guys
we're excited to enter the new year got
a lot I got a lot of I have this whole
note right here that's titled special
YouTube video ideas that we wanted to do
and also oh yeah a big THANK YOU to the
patrons actually because the people I
thought we gave time outside we touched
on the patreon but a big thank you to
the patrons because when this happened
we learned a lot about what makes
patreon so special to is with patreon we
realize in this process that the patrons
become like a second youtube channel for
us it's more than just like pledge and
then you get some perks like you really
get a whole other video segments like a
bunch
oh yeah when we shoot a whole lot and
it's like with with YouTube's content
guidelines our patreon now is sort of
the place for the uncut feed you know
yeah there's the Ross the raw free form
more of a
just want to do like on the on the $5 of
segments it's like a exclusive patreon
reactions just reactions to stuff that
we want to do or recommendations from
patrons on there and then for the $1 it
up it gives you access to the monthly
Q&A which has been one of my favorite
things to do because a lot of fun it's
not a live stream it's not like we just
answer a question for 30 seconds to a
minute usually we take it we make a
video response to every question which
usually becomes a full-on video usually
becomes a discussion yeah it becomes a
talk it's like a new new discussion type
of game and it's been so much fun and a
lot of you guys raised your pledges
because of what we were going through so
really do appreciate that like people
like Matt beer and Rosa Parra and David
Gandy and specifically you guys are
Maria's raise your pledges to help out
so I really appreciate that and of
course you know Gareth hood as well so
yeah the patrons and well it's been a
lot of support I feel like like this
experience showed us we have a lot of
friends in the community on friends a
lot of support a lot of love yeah so
it's it's actually what start off is one
of the worst experiences became one of
the most enlightening experiences as
well and I mean just thank you to
everybody who and all the other
subscribers who started like spreading
the word and helping us out and show in
the support so thank you because it's
more than just the people we named here
I mean we've had people on the page
commenting people retweeting stuff for
us yeah liking and people we didn't even
contact who just out of the kindness and
of their hearts and out of the interest
in our channel decided to do that so
yeah really like if you're watching this
at all thank you as that's been the most
reassuring that's one of the most
reassuring part and we're gonna keep the
uploads going we're gonna spread we have
figured out the order we're gonna upload
we got to figure out how many dollars
yes all all the Star Wars video yeah we
just got our first week we got every
we're gonna watch Jumanji in like a half
hour so we got to get this up right of
web but in all sincerity we're happy to
be back we love you guys and excited to
for a new year and it for the new year
and hopefully you guys like keep loving
our videos much love subscribe to the
real rejects yay